hey what's up yeah I read Malcolm
Gladwell so what does that mean I'm
smarter than you
yeah I'm something of a bookworm because
of Malcolm Gladwell I never think about
anything for more than 30 seconds well
thank you I haven't read blink yet
that's for losers who don't understand
this science being judgmental is for
scholars who understand the science
because of blink eye now judge books by
their cover you understand more by
understanding less yeah it's complicated
okay
he takes what you think you know flips
it on its head and then makes you feel
as if you've always known it yeah so
what if the science disagrees with it
Matt Malcolm he's a New York Times best
seller okay
I'm just gonna say that I read New York
Times bestseller oh hey what's up just
thin slice I'm judging books by their
cover it's science check this out I
haven't read a single one of these books
great bad good good better best this is
the best book here look at that cover I
thin-sliced it I'm thin slicing you
right now as we speak I'm thin slicing
you and you know what I don't like what
I say